thank you
a fourth day of protests in yereva
hundreds are calling for prime minister
Nicole pashinyan to resign they're
saying he's abandoned ethnic Armenians
in nagorno-karabakh a region they call
artzach this is a shame of our nation
that our government
with the face of Nicole
is not
taking all the required measures to save
Armenians wherever they should be
the Prime Minister says Armenia is
preparing to accept people who leave
nagorna karabakh if it becomes
impossible for them to stay under
azerbaijani rule
if it's determined that it will be
impossible for them to live in their
homes if the situation does not improve
then this problem will be on our agenda
we have done some work and now 40 000
places have been prepared in Armenia the
region is recognized internationally as
azerbaijani territory but it has been
self-governing for nearly three decades
with strong ties to yet Ivan ethnic
Armenians have been living there for
Generations
Azerbaijan and Armenia have fought two
Wars sparked by this dispute most
recently in 2020 but after a sudden
azerbaijani offensive this week karabakh
Fighters have agreed to disarm
azerbaijan's government says they will
have a choice to stay or to leave we
agreed that or who is going to put down
his guns and not be using a force
against an Azerbaijan and azerbaijanic
forces simply they should be set free
and they should decide with a state to
Parabola or go to Armenia is here our
ultimate decision
have yet to agree on security guarantees
for ethnic Armenians and other issues
but they have started removing some road
blockades with the first humanitarian
Aid since the ceasefire coming in on
Friday
Dimitri medvedenko Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera